am persischen golf in mitten des
arabischen emirates dubai das größte
gebäude der welt mit 828 metern aus der
bis zu viel erwischt kann ach ja und das
bin ich in 23 jahre und so unsportlich
wie noch über 160 nutzbaren stockwerken
ca 2900 treppen trennen den höchsten
belebten historischem boden und für
gewöhnlich überwindet man diese hört mit
einem der 57 aufzüge und ihr merkt
wahrscheinlich schon in welche richtung
das hier gerade geht ich habe mich
gefragt ob ein normal sterblicher mensch
wie ich es schaffen kann diese distanz
mit treppensteigen zu überwinden und vor
allem wie lange dafür wohl brauchen
würde deswegen habe ich genau das bot
punkt ich habe keine ahnung wie schwer
es im endeffekt wirklich ist gerade mit
meiner aktuellen körperlichen verfassung
ich habe im letzten jahr mindestens
zwölf kilo zugenommen mich wenig bewegt
und wer ist der glimmstängel zu mir
genommen aber glaubst du dass ich
schaffe glaube schritt laienhafte
meinung ich werde mich entblößen müssen
leo du musst mich pixeln
wir müssen hier nicht nur mein
körpergewicht das genau 88 5 kilo weg
sondern auch meinen bmi und meinen
körper fit körperfett von 17,2 prozent
ein bmw- von 24,8 körperfett ist schon
im orangen im bereich und vielleicht
wenn wir das hier mit einer mal wieder
deutlich übertriebenen aktionen in die
richtige richtung bringt das dränge sich
aber schon diverse male unter beweis
gestellt dass ich meinen inneren
schweinehund überwinden kann
ich meine er bei der fahrradtour oder
beim aus dem bergsteigen oder beim
marathon laufen das problem ist das
ganze ist jetzt schon eine längere zeit
her das letzte mal als ich meinen
inneren schweinehund überwinden wollte
war bisher aus wald und dadurch
eingepackt deswegen bin ich auf der
suche nach neuen challenges und das hier
scheint die perfekte zu sein um
reinzukommen insgesamt ist das ding über
800 meter hoch über 300 stockwerke knapp
3000 treppenstufen und ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung wie lange das
dauert oder ob ich es schaffen kann und
genau deswegen gehen und probiere es
einfach aus hoch auf dem berg es ist
zeit im burj khalifa zu besteigen fühle
mich nicht besonders fit aber den
kleinen burj khalifa wird es wohl
reichen an
burj khalifa das höchste gebäude der
erde
für die nächsten paar stunden keine
ahnung wie lange das dauern soll hier
kommen halte ich die ganzen
wir werden versuchen aus dem haus kam
nicht zustande
[Musik]
ich danke apple watch um genau verfolgen
zu können wie viel kalorien ich
verbrauche und wie oft mein herz pro
minute schlägt am gerät gibt es im
prinzip nur einzustellen wie viele
treppenstufen man pro minute laufen will
und es werden geschäfte stockwerke
angezeigt irgendwie das gefühl dass 60
stufen die minute allerdings bringen wie
hoch wir auf 90 stufen die wut oder
somit als kaum stufen pro sekunde dachte
ich eine gute pace gefunden zu haben um
schnell zu sein aber es trotzdem noch
irgendwie schaffen zu können also erst
mal treppen steigen
[Musik]
das ist schon mal ziemlich flott
noch vier minuten
das fix
[Musik]
es ging schnell sogar schneller als
gedacht damit meine ich aber nicht nur
treppen streichen sondern auch mein herz
nach gerade mal fünf minuten hatte ich
schon kurz kommt über 170 und war
ziemlich laut und heftig erwarten
allgemein hat es mir in der kurzen zeit
schon deutlich mehr abverlangt als ich
gedacht hätte genau so ging es erstmal
weiter stufe um stufe stockwerk um
stockwerk unklar ist wurde immer
anstrengender aber als ich gesehen habe
dass in den ersten zehn minuten schon
knapp 50 stockwerke geschafft habe
konnte ich ordentlich motivation tanken
ich habe vorher keine idee ob man das
überhaupt schaffen würde und wenn man
schaffen würde dachte ich mann der
stunde unterwegs hochgerechnet bei 50
stockwerken zehn minuten wird es aber
bedeuten dass sich gerade mal 25 weitere
minuten beschäftigt sein würden also
nochmal fokussiert und weitergemacht
[Musik]
irgendwann wirklich wie aus dem nichts
habe ich angefangen so unendlich krass
zu schützen wie ich es vorher noch nie
erlebt habe und das wasser stand auf
meine haut also kein witz an beiden
abend konnte man dem schweiz zu gucken
wie er aus der haut kam und nicht nur an
den armen sondern auch im gesicht ich
glaube einfach wegen der
kontinuierlichen anstrengungen und der
tatsächlich gar nicht so geringen
temperatur im fitnessstudio aber das war
gar nicht so schlimm damit konnte man
eher noch das klima beim burj khalifa
simulieren irgendwie aber auch cool weil
man direkt das gefühl hatte dass der
sport was bewirkt und man konnte quasi
zu gucken wie der körper arbeitet nach
18 minuten hatte ich bereits 350
kalorien verbrannt und hier wurde es
jetzt richtig schlimm ich hatte das
gefühl meine füße gerade noch so auf die
treppenstufen zu bekommen und irgendwie
ist alles deutlich schwieriger geworden
und hat sich fast so ein bisschen taub
angefühlt zu diesem zeitpunkt war ich
bei circa 90 stockwerken aber was soll's
augen zu und durch das musste
weitergehen
irgendwann so bei stockwerk 120 ging es
plötzlich mit der laune und der
verfassung wieder bergauf keine ahnung
warum aber es ging mir plötzlich alles
wieder deutlich einfacher von der hand
und ich bin einfach gelaufen vielleicht
auch weil man das ziel so ein bisschen
vor augen hatte und es nur noch die
letzten 20 stockwerken
die letzten zehn stockwerke danach den
schlecht
was soll ich sagen ich bin unter 30
minuten alle 160 stockwerk des burj
khalifas genossen aber eigentlich stimmt
das nicht so ganz der burj khalifa hat
163 beliebt stockwerke und das war mega
am set ist fein ich hätte die drei
stockwerke noch easy geschafft habe aber
vorher nicht richtig geguckt und hab
dann bei 160 gestoppt anstatt bei 163
und ich war richtig ab gefolgt ich war
wirklich richtig fertig das habe ich
über den ganzen tag und den nächsten tag
dann auch noch gemerkt weil ich am
nächsten tag nicht vernünftig laufen
konnte es war wirklich wieder eine
anstrengung von null auf hundert aber
was hat das jetzt eigentlich mit meinem
körper gemacht wie viele kalorien habe
ich verbrannt wie warm eine
durchschnittliche herzfrequenz und hat
es irgendwas an meinem bmi meinem körper
fett oder meinem gewicht gemacht das
finale ganz kurz vorweg ich bin
tatsächlich nicht nur einmal 160
stockwerke gelaufen ich war den tag
davor im fitnessstudio hat schon mal
probiert bin dann kurz runter gegangen
vom gerät und dachte ich mach zehn
minuten pause zwischen nicht runter
gegangen man hat er gesagt oh no human
die texte training training ist
abgebrochen das bedeutet ich habe
innerhalb von 24 stunden nicht 160
stockwerke gemacht sondern so ungefähr
220 das muss man bedenken wenn wir uns
jetzt mein körpergewicht mein körper
fett und so weiter anschaut wie viel ist
denn jetzt dabei umgekommen
was soll ich da
gesagt dass sie extrem geil man also
bestückt
das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein 87,15
kilo das tier war die messung davor
88,5 jetzt 87,15 von
24,8 bmi auf 24 4 bmw und von 17,2
prozent körperfett auf 16,6 ich habe
keine ahnung ob es sein kann schreibt
mir bitte in die kommentare ob das in
irgendeiner weise möglich ist mit einer
beziehungsweise 2 so voll power aktionen
so dem körper zu schleppen oder so viel
daran zu machen das ding ist ich habe ja
auch von meiner apple watch ziemlich
genaue daten und diese daten sagen
folgendes nur im zweiten training habe
ich
648 kilokalorien verbrannt weil das muss
man sich mal überlegen in einer halben
stunde ich glaube es ist die möglichkeit
wenn man jetzt noch kurz vorm sommer
irgendwie fit werden will 170 schläge
pro minute hat mein herz gemacht
durchschnittlich das bedeutet selbst
wenn ich mal 150 hatte also ein bisschen
runtergekommen bin muss ich dafür dann
190 gehabt haben um durchschnittlich wir
uns kommen was ziemlich ziemlich krank
ist also ich war völlig verrückt
eigentlich war dieses video für den
zweiteiler geplant hat jetzt im
endeffekt aber so viel spaß gemacht dass
wir uns dafür entschieden haben dass auf
dem hauptkanal rauszuhauen das lernen
leichter wenn ich das video gefallen hat
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
schreibt in die kommentare was ich sonst
noch so ausprobieren kann um mich selber
wieder zu optimieren und irgendwie zu
dem punkt zu kommen wo ich zufrieden mit
mir selber bin wir sehen uns am sonntag
schon wieder zum nächsten video macht es
gut bis dahin